today on the matt well show state farm
is caught trying to sexualize and
indoctrinate children just another
groomer corporation to add to the list
also ricky gervais mocks gender ideology
and his latest netflix special and the
left is
not pleased shall we say and a male
teacher brags about wearing panties to
school so he can come out to his
students these people just get creepier
by the second plus whoopi goldberg tries
to chime in on the nancy pelosi
communion situation and humiliates
herself in the process in our daily
cancellation a white mlb player is
suspended for making a racist comment
except the only problem is that the
comment was not even remotely racist and
you'd have to be a lunatic to think
otherwise we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt won't show
[Music]
interest rates will continue to rise
until inflation is contained and that's
why it's important to remain on top of
your spending and your debt and to make
sure you're not wasting money on high
interest fees this is not a time where
anyone can afford to waste money you can
get a great deal right now by calling
our friends over at american financing
america's home for home loans with
american financing you'll get a free
mortgage review from a salary based
consultant there will be no pressure no
obligation and no upfront or hidden fees
just a simple conversation around cus
custom loan programs that can fit your
budget better from flexible terms to
accessing cash and even debt
consolidation it really could mean up to
a thousand dollars in monthly savings
plus of course tens of thousands in the
long term so you're saving money long
term and short term think of the
difference this could make uh for you
right now and throughout your life and
then once you've thought about that give
them a call to learn more if you start
soon you could close in as fast as 10
days you got to pick up your phone first
and dial 180 rather eight six six five
six nine 47 eleven that's eight six six
five nine 569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls
182-334-nmls consumeraccess.org
you know state farms motto declares
itself a good neighbor but as has now
been pointed out by many online they are
more like weird creepy neighbors peeking
out the window at your children while
they play in the front yard leaked
emails obtained by a group called
consumers first show that the company
was conspiring with an organization
called the gender cool project to
indoctrinate and sexualize children as
young as five years old now
why would an insurance company be
getting involved in something like this
what's the point
is there anywhere we can go in society
to be free from the grasp of groomers
the answer to the last question is
obviously no as the washington examiner
reported yesterday quote the auto
insurance company state farm is
encouraging its agents in florida to
donate books promoting transgenderism to
five-year-olds to their local schools or
public libraries according to an email
shared by a whistleblower the email
revealed that state farm has partnered
with the gender cool project which
promotes issues of gender identity in
children through various advocacy and
public awareness programs to donate a
packet of three books to local schools
and public libraries the three books are
a kid's book about being transgender
a kid's book about being non-binary and
a kid's book about being inclusive and
they contain various descriptions about
gender and identity meant to disprove
the notion that gender is the same as
biological sex and established that it
is therefore changeable the gender cool
project markets the three-book bundle to
children ages five and over
a fact noted in the whistleblower email
now
if you're curious about the gender cool
project it is
of course everything that you expect i
looked into it a little bit it was
apparently founded by two parents jen
and john whose son chazy
as uh as they describe it came out as a
girl at the age of nine that again is
how they describe the situation came out
as a girl of course it's impossible for
a boy to come out as a girl or be a girl
but that's what they say by age 11 two
years later
they had founded their activist
organization and they had scored
partnerships with not just state farm
but companies like nike general mills
intel capital one
so you see how quickly and to what
extent you can be propped up and funded
by the most powerful corporations in the
world if you affirm the predominant
gender and sexuality doctrines of the
day
just come out and say oh we're starting
an organization to promote trans stuff
and immediately you're going to have
every major corporation in the world
knocking on your door and saying we'd
like to give you some money
and you also see how quickly these
parents
took their their son's gender confusion
and turned it into a career
for them
that's all the boy's choice though they
claim right i mean he can do what he
wants
they're simply affirming him
but meanwhile they've they've taken him
and they've put him up on the stage
under the spotlight and they've turned
him into a mascot and a political symbol
see this is not affirmation this is
cementation they are cementing him in
place as a girl
that's what
everything that work that they call
affirming it's not affirming it's
cementing
it's like
what you are right now with the gender
confusion
we want you to stay just like that
he can't change his mind now the boy
you know that's how he's gonna see it
and that's the message that these
parents and so many parents of trans
kids quote unquote uh that's what the
message is and it's very intentional
and it's not very subtle
in the about section on their website
they give this explanation they say in
2017 the parents jen and john search for
positive stories about transgender and
non-binary kiddos like chazy
turned up uh nearly empty they could
count on one hand the positive stories
they found focused on who these young
people are as talented amazing leaders
in stark contrast it took all of five
seconds to find a title wave of
misleading sensational negative content
about these amazing young people
there's a couple of problems here first
of all you notice and they and they
always do this where they say well these
these kids are leaders they're leaders
no no they're not
your nine-year-old is not a leader of
anything and is not supposed to be
okay there's nothing that your
nine-year-old is supposed to be leading
except maybe uh the line on the way to
you know to
to lunch to the cafeteria
if they still even do single file lines
in schools i don't know
other than that there's nothing he's
supposed to be leading he's not a leader
among all the other problems of course
with taking gender confused kids and
affirming them in their confusion or
rather cementing them into the confusion
um
this is one of the problems on the list
is that they always want to take these
kids oh you're going to be a leader now
we're going to put you up
on stage you're going to be the leader
of a
movement and we're all depending on you
you can't change your mind of course
that's the message but as far as uh
their claim that you know there's all
the negative content about trans kids no
there's there's no negative content
about trans kids nobody is attacking
these children or criticizing them or
blaming them for anything i've never
heard anyone
attack a quote trans nine-year-old no
one's doing that no
we are attacking criticizing and blaming
the parents
not the kids
parents like this they say that they're
trying to shield their children from the
transphobic bigots who are attacking
them but in reality they're using their
children as a shield from the people
criticizing them
the parents
so with that background we can go back
to the washington examiner article and
the state farm and says the project's
goal is to increase representation of
lgbtq plus books and support our
communities and having challenging
important and empowering conversations
with children age five plus the email
said
dated january 18th the email was sent by
jose soto a corporate responsibility
analyst for state farm in florida and in
addition to promoting the company's
partnership with gender cool project it
sought to recruit six state farm
insurance agents in florida to receive
these books in march then donate them to
their community by the end of april this
is a fantastic way to give back an easy
project that will help support the lgbtq
plus community and to make the world
around us better the email added while
the communique only refer referenced
recruiting volunteer agents in florida
it indicated that the project is a
nationwide initiative
well it was a nationwide initiative
anyway less than 12 hours after this was
all made public state farm having
fielded thousands of complaints from
rightfully outraged customers who you
know just want to they just want auto
insurance they never intended to fund a
nationwide grooming program with their
money and after receiving all that
backlash they announced that the program
was being canceled the daily wire
reports
state farm is backing down monday after
outrage over its plan to donate books
promoting transgenderism to schools and
public libraries for children as young
as five years old
quote state farm support of a
philanthropic program gender cool has
been the subject of news and customer
inquiries reads a may 23 email from
victor terry state farm's chief
diversity officer to state farm agents
according to the popular twitter account
lives of tick tock the program was
intended to promote inclusivity but
state farm will no longer support it
quote conversations about gender
identity should happen at home with
parents reads terry's email we don't
support required curriculum in schools
on this topic we will no longer support
that program
he said we will continue to explore how
we can support organizations that
provide tools and resources that align
with our commitment to diversity and
inclusion the company also said that it
supports organizations providing
resources for parents to have these
conversations
ah so
these conversations should be happening
at home you say
and it only took an afternoon of intense
backlash to help them arrive at this
conclusion
and this goes to show
a couple of things a couple of lessons
that we've already learned a million
times already
but what's once more
the first is that as we see once again
there is a conspiracy at every level of
society
and among the richest and most powerful
people
to turn your children trans okay this is
happening it's an actual conspiracy and
the conspiracy conspirators have had
enormous success
but the second is that the plan relies
heavily on the cover of darkness
all you have to do is just
turn the lights on
and the whole thing starts to fall apart
so our goal now should be to turn on
every lamp in the house
leave no dark rooms or corners
expose it all
let the light
shine
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
the rise in popularity of cryptocurrency
over the last decade has attracted
legitimate investors as well as
fraudsters these cyber criminals use
ponzi schemes fake investment scams
trading scams and fake giveaways to
steal your money and your personal
information that's why it's important to
remember to never reply to messages that
sound too good to be true especially
when it comes to your savings and it's
so important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives your personal information gets
exposed so often that makes it
dangerously easy for a cyber criminal to
steal your identity and steal
everything else your life your
reputation your money protect your
identity
has never been easier with lifelock by
norton lifelock detects and alerts you
to potential identity threats that you
may not spot on your own like loans
taken out in your name and other threats
as well if you become a victim of
identity theft they have a dedicated
us-based restoration specialist that
will work to fix it nobody can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but it's
easy to help protect yourself with
lifelock
identity theft protection starts here
join now and save 25 off your first year
at lifelock.com walsh that's
lifelock.com walls for 25 off
all right so you know c.s lewis uh
begins
his book
the screwtape letters with a quote from
i think it was uh if i remember
correctly saint thomas more
saying that the devil could not endure
to be mocked and uh and
and that's why he should be because
that's the appropriate response to evil
is to mock it that shouldn't be our only
response to evil but that is an
appropriate response that should be a
big part of our rebuttal as it were to
evil because evil is uh proud and it's
uh arrogant haughty self-involved
narcissistic and and it you know props
itself up above everybody but it's
propped up on stilts
which can easily be kicked and knocked
over
which is exactly what we should be doing
and that's why i'm a huge proponent of
mocking
gender ideology which is from the devil
and ironically ricky gervais uh doesn't
believe in the in the devil because you
know he's an atheist
but he does a great job of mocking him
um including in this there's a there's a
a bit from his new
netflix special which i think was just
um launched on netflix yesterday and
this bit's going viral and uh of course
it has the left very very angry
and here he is making jokes about gender
ideology now the thing is
you know
dave chappelle gets sort of the credit
as being the brave comedian who will
you know make jokes about the trans
phenomenon and all that kind of stuff
i've always thought that
dave chappelle's jokes are i appreciate
that he's making them at all i guess but
the jokes are i've always thought kind
of pretty pretty safe and tame
um he doesn't go nearly as far as he
could
it always seems to me that dave
chappelle even though he gets credit or
blame depending on how you want to you
know depending on your perspective
uh for being the guy who who will talk
about these kinds of things it always
seems to me like he pulls his punches
and on top of that also uh his his
recent stand-up specials i just think
aren't that funny like he's not making a
lot of jokes he's just sort of up there
preaching and but what he's saying in
his preaching isn't really all that
provocative or edgy you know at all um
but here i think ricky gervais
really goes for it
really goes for it so let's listen to
this
the old-fashioned women oh god you know
the ones with wombs
those dinosaurs
[Music]
no i love the the new whip i know
they're new but they're great aren't
they you know the new ones we've been
seeing lately they were the ones with
beards and they're as good as
they're as good as gold i love them
now it's the old fashioned way and now
the old fashioned they go like oh they
want to use our toilets why shouldn't
they use your toilets for ladies
they are ladies look at their pronouns
what about this person isn't a lady well
his penis
her penis you [ __ ] figure
what if he raped me
what if she raped you
[Music]
now the great thing is that yeah that's
funny but that is also
exactly what the trans activists
actually say like he didn't say anything
in this uh imaginary conversation
between a sane person and trans activist
he is fairly representing and this is
this is this shows you how absurd it is
that he could stand on stage as a
stand-up comedian
and simply say exactly what these people
actually say and it's a it's a hilarious
punch line because that's how insane it
is
her penis like that's that's what they
say that is 100
what they say there's absolutely no
straw manning going on there at all
and um is this the right approach like
should should we be doing this
should comedians be up there should
anyone be making jokes about this um
yes
absolutely
because the claims that the gender
ideologues are making and what they're
doing it's it's very serious it's
incredibly damaging
they're hurting people
they're mutilating kids
they're killing people actually putting
kids on a path to despair and suicide so
it's very serious on one hand
but also
their whole world view is totally insane
and ludicrous
and so while we should deal with it on
the serious level as well we should also
highlight just how ludicrous it is
mockery is a very important tool that i
think up until recently
especially when it comes to gender
ideology um
the the sane people have been really
reluctant to use it's a tool that we've
been very reluctant to use
and i say we like not me because i
haven't been reluctant to use it but but
generally speaking you know it's sort of
the universal we we've been very
reluctant to use this very powerful tool
and it's a tool that the left has um
until recently until they launched their
all-out war like comedy's not allowed
now on the left they don't believe in it
but up until that until they want full
puritan right um
the the tool of mockery is something
they use to great effect
and yes we should be using it here
to again highlight that this is
ludicrous
no we're not gonna take it seriously
okay the moment you start talking about
women with penises
this is not
this is not like we're gonna sit down
and have a conversation about it and
take your point of view seriously
okay the moment you talk about men
having babies
we're not going to dignify that by
pretending that there's anything
credible in your claim whatsoever
you're going to be mocked for that
because it's insane
but then
so i wish i could just end it there and
say about ricky gervais great job great
routine uh takes takes it does
legitimately take courage to do what he
did there
and they're going to come after him i
mean if they went after think again
think about what chappelle said about
all this
really mild
okay there's nothing like that at all
and so if they went after chappelle
uh
they're gonna have to and on top of it
gervais is also a white man
he's going a lot harder against this uh
than chappelle ever did so they're going
to come after him it's just going to be
the hounds of hell after this guy and so
that takes a lot of courage absolutely
it shouldn't take courage
this is your job you know you make jokes
you're a comedian
most comedians make jokes about things
that are happening in society this is
the role this is why comedians are
important they're supposed to you know
they're supposed to poke the um
the the sacred cows you know
the elephant in the rooms that we don't
talk about in society those are the
things they're supposed to be pointing
at and laughing at that's that's the
role that they are supposed to play is
what makes them important so
um and all that's good and i wish i
could leave it right there
but then in the daily wire article about
this
uh it says this
quoting ricky gervais in the same
special i guess shortly after that bit
right there he says
okay full disclosure in real life of
course i support trans rights i support
all human rights and trans rights are
human rights
live your best life use your preferred
pronoun well
first of all
that's not gonna save you
ricky like it's
there's nothing there's no qualifier you
can add at the end of that
that's going to blunt the impact when
they come after you they're going to try
to destroy you now and there's nothing
you could say afterwards
nothing that's going to change that
so you might as well just let the joke
stand
the joke which is not really a joke
right just let it stand and move on to
your next material there's no reason
the qualifier oh of course i support
trans rights
the moment you say that it's just it it
it
has the effect it un to
it what's going to undo everything you
just said
because well you support trans rights
well but they would tell us that it is a
matter of trans rights that biological
men should be able to use the women's
room
so do you support that then
or maybe you just mean that well i
support human rights and so i support
the human rights of all people including
trans people
well yes if that's what you mean then we
can agree on that because anyone who
believes that human rights exist
believes that they exist in all people
but that's when you say trans rights
that's not what anyone means when they
say that that's not what the trans
people mean
they don't just mean oh i want the same
rights as everybody else
no that's not what they mean
because if you just wanted the same
rights as everybody else then you
wouldn't need to put the qualifier of it
trans right i want trans rights oh you
just be out there saying i want human
rights
and any trans person marching saying i
want human rights i fully agree you
should have human rights here's the good
news you have them so you're fine like
no one is taking them from you you have
them you're good to go you can put the
sign down go and live your life because
you have human rights you have the same
rights as anybody
so no when they when they march for
trans rights they want more than that
they want they want rights on top of
human rights
okay they want to be able to do things
that other people can't do
prior to trans rights everybody had the
same rules and had to respect the same
rules with when it comes to bathrooms
you use the bathroom okay that that is
in accordance with your biological
identity
that's it
doesn't matter how you feel doesn't
matter what's going on in your head
doesn't matter how you identify just
that's it everyone uses the same one
you're coming along and saying no no i
want i want an exception to that i want
to be the exception
and so that's what the trans activists
are doing
they want to be one exception after
another i want to be exception to this i
want to be the exception to that
i want you to reorient society around me
i want you to toss reality truth
biological science common sense decency
i want you to toss all that out the
window for me
so whether you mean it or not when you
say i support trans rights that is what
you are supporting because that is what
everybody means when they talk about
trans
rights so that's just
man
it's like people come
so close
and it's just this this to me is even
more frustrating than just having
someone who affirms the trans stuff and
like everybody else it's like when you
cut when you you get right up to the
edge
of just being an advocate for the truth
without qualification you get right up
to the edge of it and then you turn back
that's frustrating
uh but even so
good uh
good routine and the good thing though
is that
especially for the trans activists and
lgbt activists who want to make victims
of themselves you know the part where
gervais says i support trans rights like
that's not gonna make it into any of the
clips all of where all anybody's gonna
see is that which is good because that's
i hope that's all anybody sees
that's the good part right there
um all right so this is from nbc news on
uh monkey pox not a lot of new
information here but this is another
mainstream media outlet picking up this
aspect of the story so maybe worth
reading it says a leading advisor to the
world health organization described the
unprecedented outbreak of the rare
disease monkey pox in developed
countries as a random event
that might be explained by risky sexual
behavior at two recent mass events in
europe in an interview with the
associated press
dr david hyman who formerly headed whose
emergency department said the leading
theory to explain the spread of the
disease was sexual transmission among
gay and bisexual men at two raves held
in spain and belgium monkey pox has not
previously triggered widespread
outbreaks beyond africa where it is
endemic in animals
um and this is now nbc news
also reporting on this that this the
super spreader events were gay
raves
okay in belgium and in um
and in spain
and then cnn has this
about you know with monkey pox we're
told about this rash it starts as flu
symptoms and then there's this rash that
you get
and cnn reports this the rash is showing
up in different parts of the body than
we typically expect to see
in some cases it has produced anal or
genital lesions that look like other
diseases like herpes chickenpox or
syphilis so anyone with a rash or lesion
around or involving their genitals their
anus or any other place that they have
not seen it before it should get fully
evaluated both for that rash
particularly for sexual transmitted
infection and other illnesses that can
cause
the rash so this just further emphasizes
that the monkey pox is essentially
a in this case anyway for this quote
unquote outbreak is a sexually
transmitted disease now
they're
they're kind of uh adding some
qualification there and saying it's it's
not technically a sexually transmitted
disease because it doesn't
transmit primarily through sex itself
but through the close contact
that you have uh with someone
when you're engaged in in that activity
but all this means you know what all
this means
and we talked about monkey pox yesterday
how it's the media's new uh thing it's
the new hysteria and it's the new
current thing so it's going to put it
puts you know
ukraine goes to the side ukraine goes
down a notch covet goes down another
notch and then monkey pox at the top
and
i think that would be the case
but now i'm not so sure i think the the
better prediction the safer prediction
now is that monkey pox story is going
away
um and it's going away because even the
mass media
can't avoid reporting
that the super spreader events was uh
were two gay
raves
and these these things are being
described different ways
like yesterday was a fetish festival now
it's a gay rave but we all get the idea
affecting primarily gay and bisexual men
like this is just not a story that the
mainstream media is going to want to
talk about
especially because as we pointed out
yesterday the contradiction here is so
glaring that they for years told us lock
yourself away in your home wear masks do
that change everything about your life
to avoid covid even your kids your kids
should have their whole lives blown
blown to pieces uh to avoid covet even
though they're not at any risk at any
serious risk
of spreading or or or contracting it
well
that would mean that the consistent
message now with monkey pogs is you
would be saying to
the gay community
uh don't go to raves and orgies and and
fetish festivals
and the only difference is that like
that's just good advice all the time
whether there's monkey pox or not
because there's all kinds of other
diseases
that you can get and people often do get
in those kinds of
environments
so that's but they're not gonna send
that message they're not gonna say that
they don't mind telling everyone in the
world to stop everything they're doing
but are they going to point to the gay
community and say
don't go to the fetish festivals
probably not a good idea
no way
at least they don't want that to be a
story they don't want that to be a big
thing
so i think now probably you're going to
see
they were kind of ramping up to make
monkey pox the new thing
and but then now that it's unavoidable
that this is primarily right now
essentially an std in gay men uh i i
think you're probably gonna see it go
away
you see see the story go away if not the
virus
um
all right let's move on to this so we're
used to
seeing these creepy disturbing teachers
and all content related to that but this
one picked up by libs of tick tock may
still shock you i want to put this tweet
up on the screen
so you can see the um
the screenshot hold on let me pull it
myself okay so lives of tick tock
reports male teacher writes about how
good it feels wearing women's
undergarments to school and coming out
as
non-binary to his students
and then we have a male teacher here and
here's the picture that he posted online
and he has his own caption says so this
is me feeling my best teacher self
because i'm wearing panties on a work
day for the first time ever and i feel
so good
um id a tall bearded demi boy with
pomaded hair and glasses wearing a
purple and white checked shirt a gray
sweater vest and a brown tweed jacket
with black jeans
and then he continues i signed up to
lead an affinity group for lgbtqia plus
students at my school a while back the
first meeting is this afternoon and i'm
going to be coming out to a bunch of
high schoolers as bi and nb
the hell is nb
and oh n like n b non-binary n b
okay i'm a bit nervous good vibe slash
encouragement are needed and welcome
and then there's another
follow-up that uh libbs tic-tock has
this is from last year march of last
year uh where he's wearing a dress as
first ever dress feels very teachery
please be kind
and then he identifies himself as a demi
boy again and if you're wondering what a
demi boy is
i had to google that and it says
an identity that describes someone who
identifies with both male and agender
genders
what the hell is agender
okay now you gotta look that up it's
just like
once you start peeling back these onions
you you know you you immediately regret
it but so agender is
an identity that does describe somebody
without gender or who does not relate to
either binary
to either binary gender
okay
so uh a demi boy quote-unquote is
someone who identifies as having a
gender and also not having one at the
same time
which just does that doesn't mean
anything at all
you know what it means
here's what all that means
because that's total nonsense okay
absolute nonsense
what it actually means for this creep
is that he has a fetish
for wearing women's underwear
around kids
and this is the label that he puts on it
to make it sound you know like something
we have to affirm and include and accept
that's what that really means in his
case
um
so this is a this is a teacher
announcing
that it feels good wearing women's
underwear
wearing panties
to school and then he's gonna he's gonna
come out to his students
like if we were to do a poll
you know we'd take this
show this to
every parent in the country with kids in
public school
um and pull all of them
what percentage do you think
would say that yeah this is the kind of
thing they want their teachers doing
well like what percentage of those
parents would be excited about the idea
of uh of a male teacher in his panties
who wears them because he says it makes
him feel good and sitting down and
coming out and to his to his students
and having a sexual conversation like
what percentage if we were to pull every
single public school parent what
percentage would say oh yeah that's
great that's like that's exactly what i
i'm hoping is happening
this is why i send my kids to school
would we get up to like 0.1 percent
would we even make it that high i really
don't think we would
which is why it's so important to keep
as we talked about turn on all the
lights
and when you turn on the lights you're
going to see a lot of things you don't
want to see
but we have to see them
because here's the other thing that we
have to keep we have to remember here is
that um
if we don't if we don't see it you know
if we allow these things to happen in
darkness our kids are still being
subjected to it
uh one other thing from libs and tick
tock another contribution not from liz
dick duck but but at least something
that uh she is revealing to us uh
staying on the subject of teacher creeps
creatures as maybe i will start calling
them here's a trans preschool
creature
uh talking about
her i think this is a female
experience is you know talking to her
kids let's watch this
so today was full of little
happy gender euphoria moments i got
called mr micah a lot today
well completely femme and that was
really heartwarming that the kids just
got it
but my favorite reaction and
it sums me up so well i feel like
is
i was in a new classroom and i took off
my mask to blow my nose and i just hear
a kid loudly whisper
oh
she's a boy
i was like yeah you got it kid you
totally got it
uh gender euphoria moments is what we're
being
told there
this is gender euphoria
and if you're wondering about that um
i'm not gonna start googling it googling
that but i i think we can just kind of
connect the dots there context clues so
gender dysphoria is when you feel like
out of place in your gender or whatever
and uh gender euphoria is when you have
feelings of elation and pleasure in
having your gender affirmed so
these are teachers that are looking for
euphoria
she i think
is looking for her
students who are like three and four
years old to provide her moments of
euphoria
depending on three and four-year-olds to
affirm her
again going back to the poll
how many parents have sent their kids to
preschool like that's what they want
you're sending your kid to preschool so
that your child will be a source of
affirmation and euphoria for the teacher
very few i imagine all right moving to
this whoopi goldberg is shedding some
some light adding some insight
to the nancy pelosi communion situation
in san francisco let's listen to that
welcome to the view y'all
the abortion rights battle is starting
to blur the lines between church and
state the archbishop
of san francisco
[Applause]
is calling for speaker nancy pelosi to
be denied receiving communion because of
her pro-choice stance he's one of the
priests who also called for president
biden to be denied sacrament this is not
your job dude
that is not you can't that is not up to
you to make that decision
you know what is the saying it's kind of
amazing uh
but
you know
what is the point of communion right
it's for uh sinners
it's the for the for sinners it's the
reward of saints but the bread of
sinners how dare you
it's not your job dude
no uh whoopi that is
literally his job that's actually
what what he is supposed to do as the
archbishop
okay now
and i does
does whoopi goldberg identify herself as
catholic i'm not actually sure about
that
whether she identifies herself that way
or not as a soft in the case these days
on the left with self-identification
it's it's false it doesn't mean anything
because she clearly whether she's
catholic or not does not understand the
basic hierarchical structure
of the uh
of of the church and by the way there is
no mixing of church and state here at
all
okay in fact if
if the archbishop had declined to
enforce the rules for nancy pelosi
because she is a high-ranking government
official
that would be church and state
um
interfering or rather it's the state
that would be the state sort of imposing
itself exercising influence in a way
that it should not
which by the way
going back to the to the phrase
separation of church and state from
thomas jefferson which is not something
that actually appears in the
constitution at all but that's what he
was referring to to the danbury baptist
that's what he was worried about he
wasn't worried about the church
interfering with the state he was
worried about the state interfering with
the church
and so
that's where you find
a as the left might use the phrase
problematic that's where things get
problematic
is if the rules are not being enforced
by people in positions of authority
because somebody is uh
is a government official or as a
high-ranking person which is the case
unfortunately in most diocese across the
country
these politicians are allowed to uh to
flout these rules
including in in washington dc
where people like nancy pelosi go to
mass and they'll especially let's go to
mass there because it's going to be
public and they're going to be on camera
and everyone's going to see them going
in like good little catholics
but they go up and and receive communion
and it's not enforced there
by the bishop in that case
that is the state
exercising influence
that's where you find the intrusion
not the other way around
um
all right one other
thing i wanted to read let me see if i
can find it
somewhere around here okay from the
daily wire a texas toddler stole his
mother's unlocked phone to play with it
and she thought nothing of it until the
doordash delivery driver showed up at
her home with 31 mcdonald's
cheeseburgers
kelsey golden shared a photo of her
two-year-old son barrett along with his
ill-gotten gains and advertised free
cheeseburgers
she says he likes to look at his
reflection noting that when he's taken
her phone before he's used the camera to
look at himself rather than trying to
find games to play her videos to watch
but he didn't appear to be using the
camera this time instead golden said
that he started pressing the screen and
then he accidentally ordered doordash
for himself for 31 cheeseburgers and she
didn't realize that he'd ordered
doordash until the doordash driver
showed up with 31 cheeseburgers and then
she was on cnn talking about it and the
story was like one of those you know
human interest stories and there's a
nice little whimsical
uh heartwarming tale about about a
precocious youngster who does this and
she's on cnn talking about it
and
man i hate to be this guy you know i do
i but
i don't really hate to be this guy
actually i kind of enjoy being this guy
i have to admit and i'm not really
buying the story i'm just not
now i'm not saying that this is
jessie smilette okay i'm not saying that
she's the jessie smilet of doordash it's
not like she claimed that the toddler
shouted this is burger king country or
something but i'm not totally buying the
story
of the kid the kid takes the phone and
then is messing with it two years old
and orders 31 cheeseburgers and then she
doesn't know about it
until the door until the
cheeseburger show up on her front door
so there's a lot of things here like
first of all you
nobody would give an unlocked phone to a
two-year-old okay you don't do that
and even if you do what are the chances
that the toddler is going to hit all the
right buttons
because there's a multiple succession of
buttons the toddler would have to hit
accidentally to get you know first you
got to scroll you know swipe over get to
the door dash thing click on that go to
burger king click on that click
accidentally on cheeseburgers and then
to get to 31 you'd have to like there's
a little uh plus sign you have to hit
that 31 times to get to the 31
and then you go through the checkup he
did all this accidentally and then
she didn't
know about it
even though she would get the
alert on her phone and it would tell her
that 31 cheeseburgers have been ordered
i'm just not buying it
you know i'm not
i think there's something else going on
here which is probably just a half made
up story for attention so maybe it
doesn't matter that much
but you know what the truth always
matters even when it comes to
cheeseburger orders
all right let's get to our
comment section
[Music]
auto i think that's what we're going
with says i heard the knife by the guy
that attacked chappelle was in a
backpack and he wasn't wielding it hence
the misdemeanor details are important
uh
it may have been in his backpack but
that still should not be a misdemeanor
okay
he snuck he was in it he snuck the
weapon in
to this event where you're not supposed
to have knives
and then he ran on stage
and violently assaulted somebody
on stage in front of
everybody and he had a weapon on him
like why did he bring the weapon was it
just was he was he cutting apples or
something
why else did he have it
we can assume that he intended to use it
i mean if somebody sneaks
uh a weapon into a public event and then
violently attack someone we can assume
that the weapon was related to this plan
to violently attack somebody
and even without
the weapon
it still should be a felony
obviously
unless you want to encourage more of
this stuff which uh which of course they
do
um
deplorable neanderthal says you give
alfred kinsey too much credit matt this
stuff comes from satan alfred was just
one willing yet influential pawn
yeah i couldn't agree with you more
there mike says matt you've raved about
the nashville zoo so much i finally went
on saturday i have to say great
recommendation we loved it well i'm glad
you know we're a big nashville zoo fans
we were on we were there on saturday
also so maybe you saw us actually we
were at the zoo on saturday
and um
and maybe tell me if this is a thing
because i was a little bit excited by
this we went to the zoo
we're walking around and then my wife
said that apparently they've got this
new exhibit at the zoo where you can go
they have this little theater thing and
you can go and it's a 3d move like
little 20-minute 3d movie that you can
say they give you 3d glasses and she
said we got to go watch the the 3d thing
it's like a 20 minute with the
characters from ice age
and of course i'm thinking well we have
a 3d exhibit
around us
it's called the zoo and everything here
is 3d so why do we need to but she
wanted to do that so we did and they
give you the 3d glasses and it's been a
while since i've watched a 3d thing you
know i don't usually go for the 3d
movies like any movie that would be in
3d in the theaters is almost always the
kind of movie i would hate which maybe
doesn't surprise you but i sat there and
i tried to watch it and i'm just in but
i put the 3d glasses on and they're not
big enough to put over my prescription
glasses i have to take my prescriptions
off put the 3d glasses on and i can't
experience
the 3d ice age thing
because it's all blurry because of my
visual impairment
and that's what i realized this is a
this is
an accessibility problem they have not
made this is the case like for all these
3d films they have not made it
accessible
for visually impaired people this is
ableism i'm a victim finally
i'm always look as you know as a as a
white male i don't have any victim
points i'm looking to find them wherever
i can i think this is a legit area i
could sue the zoo and probably bankrupt
them
because it's your responsibility as a
visually impaired american i expect you
should have prescription 3d glasses for
every possible prescription available
in limitless supply
and if you don't you've excluded me as a
visually impaired as a member of the
visually impaired community
um
so i get at least one victim point from
that i think we can agree
uh let's see skill mayor says matt
i came home to my wife leaving a gift on
my pillow the other day i looked inside
the bag and it was a sweet baby gang
shirt i broke down with tears of joy
that my wife understands me so well is
this form of crying acceptable or am i
banned from the show
uh that is obviously
we're gonna add that there's seven
acceptable reasons for a man to cry
that'll be number eight so you just you
snuck in by the skin of your teeth
um
and amanda says our daughter started
showing signs of puberty before her
second birthday because there's
something wrong with the way her body's
developing due to a traumatic brain
injury as an infant it's disgusting that
people try to equate the difficulties of
our lives that are dominated with
specialist therapy special equipment and
fighting with insurance companies to
purposefully stunting typically
developing children it's not even close
to the same thing it will be disgusted
by a parent insisting their healthy
child be put through chemotherapy for no
reason this is no different
a lot of comments from parents in
similar situations with with kids that
have precocious puberty and that is an
actual medical condition where the drugs
that we call puberty blockers might be
used
for medical reasons but as we heard from
person the daily cancellation yesterday
trying to equate the two things well if
you use puberty blockers for that then
clearly using them for gender confused
people it's the same thing
so it's like every drug on the market
has a specific
purpose
every prescription drug anyway
and there are prescription drugs that
have that
you know there are so many of them that
there are certain ones that i would say
probably nobody should be using but they
all have a specific purpose
in theory anyway
and just because they exist doesn't mean
that any purpose you come up
with for it is is legitimate obviously
and one of the i think i mentioned it
yesterday one of the um one of the
reasons why
with precocious puberty you might use
quote-unquote puberty blockers in a
legitimate medical context
is because it actually can lead to
stunted growth
because you know this is the way our
bodies are supposed to work for kids
bodies after puberty your body kind of
begins to stop growing
and so if you go through puberty when
you're seven years old
then your body's going to stop growing
at the end of that and you're going to
end up you know with stunted growth
at the end of it
and so that's a physical
consequence of this condition
and it's something that puberty blockers
might help
with
but if you're giving it to a kid who
does not have any physical condition
whatsoever then
rather than preventing stunted growth
you're actually going to cause it and
that's what often happens when you use
drugs in ways that they're not supposed
to be used
well as you know by now the event of the
summer backstage live at the ryman is
back on june 29th at the historic ryman
auditorium in nashville tennessee and
due to historic demand we've opened up
some more tickets to the event so
there's still time to get in on the fun
and watch your favorite daily wire host
live and unfiltered what's backstage
live well glad you asked check it out
welcome to the daily wire backstage live
at the famous ryman auditorium
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people and to
just you know feel that energy who
should we remove from office one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
backstage live happens right here in
nashville on june 29th get your tickets
now
and this year we're going even bigger so
get your tickets for backstage live
today at dailywire.com
ryman you're not going to want to miss
this now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
yeah i don't follow baseball because i
typically prefer to watch sports instead
but there's a baseball controversy which
demands the attention of the daily
cancellation we'll begin at the at the
end here with new york yankees third
baseman josh donaldson
getting suspended by the mlb and fined
for making an inappropriate comment to
chicago white sox player tim anderson
donaldson is white anderson is black and
this already tells you of course that
the inappropriate comment did not need
to actually be inappropriate at all in
order to provoke a punishment and in
this case you'll be shocked to discover
just how not inappropriate the comment
in fact was it was a it was a wholly
appropriate comment actually and yet
he's punished for it but the media has
taken this the other way declaring that
the comment was not only inappropriate
but you guessed it racist bleacher
report states as as much in their
headline they say yankees josh donaldson
suspended for making racist comment to
tim anderson
and deadspin never one to let a race
hustle go to waste declares
just say it josh donaldson made a racist
comment to tim anderson
sports illustrated tells us that josh
donaldson is embroiled in a racism
controversy
meanwhile other people in the league
including the white sox manager
have also accused donaldson of racism so
there's consensus agreement it would
seem
that josh donaldson is a raging bigot
who hurled an outrageous racist slur
at tim anderson
and in case you're wondering
what the slur was it was of course the j
word
yes the j word the dreaded j word um
that being jackie
he called anderson jackie as in jackie
robinson
and that's why he's suspended
but why is it inappropriate much less
racist to compare a baseball player to
jackie robinson isn't that like someone
being offended as an artist if if you
compare them to michelangelo
well if you go up to an artist and say
hey michelangelo
well how dare you call me that slur
how does that make any sense
well maybe it'll help to hear from tim
anderson himself the victim of this
hurtful compliment after the game he was
he was uh practically in tears crying
about how disrespected he feels but why
does he feel disrespected let's listen
and see if we find out
yeah he just made a you know
disrespectful coming
uh you know baseball is you know trying
to call me jackie robinson's like what's
up jackie um
you know
uh i don't i don't play like that you
know i don't i don't really play at all
um
you know i wasn't i wasn't really
bothering nobody today but uh you know
he made a comment you know it was
disrespectful
and uh i don't think it was called
foreign
[Music]
first time he got home you know and i
spared him that time didn't happen again
and you know it was just you know it's
just uncalled for you know it's not like
i got time to you know be playing like
that how did you manage to contain
yourself
that kind of comment
you know
i don't know be honest
you know i don't know to be honest uh
you know it was very disrespectful you
know i don't want to play like that
i mean first of all that you gotta love
these athlete interviews because they
know like three words and they just it
was very disrespectful i don't play like
that it was uncalled for and you know
the thing is it was uncalled for and i
don't play like that and it's
disrespectful
it was just it was just disrespectful
it's uncalled for
you know what i don't play like that i
was uncalling for disrespect just over
and over and over again repeating
themselves um but if you couldn't hear
clearly the reporter actually asked
anderson
how he managed to continue playing after
experiencing something as devastating as
being called jackie the reporter asked
him that and not sarcastically how did
you manage to continue playing
anderson doesn't know how he continued
but somehow against all odds he was able
to compose himself
pick up the pieces and
soldier on for a few more innings what a
hero
as for why the comment was so hurtful or
racist we didn't get much of an
explanation from anderson all we got was
him saying he doesn't play like that and
whining like a [ __ ] because this is
what professional athletes are and what
they do these days i'm reminded of
lebron james she remembered this he
called security on a couple of fans in
the front row because they said a mean
word to him like he actually brought
security over and pointed at them they
said it they were mean put them in
timeout
professional athletes may have physical
strength but emotionally and
psychologically they're a bunch of
jellyfish i mean flimsy weak
invertebrates constantly whimpering
about their feelings getting hurt
in the case of tim anderson we haven't
even gotten to the most salient detail
which is this
he called himself jackie robinson it
turns out that donaldson's comment was
not a compliment okay he was indeed
teasing anderson but he was teasing him
for comparing himself to jackie robinson
in an interview a few years ago
so it was a little bit of very light
trash talk
and well deserved because you shouldn't
go around comparing yourself to jackie
robinson
going back to the artist example this is
like of an artist labeled himself said
i'm the new michelangelo
should he make that mistake he would
have to deal with people mockingly
calling him michelangelo for the rest of
his life he brought it on himself
so how can donaldson be labeled racist
actually suspended and fined
for calling anderson something that he'd
already called himself
well over on espn sports talking head
marcus spears
attempts to make sense of all of this
i don't want to
try to decipher between what donaldson
meant i just want to give him
um
potentially why this
would send the type of reaction from tim
anderson that it would it's because of
the times we're in it's because of the
things that have transpired over the
years is because of how sports have been
involved in racial equality and and
taking things head on that comes along
with the game i'm not going to cast any
aspersions on donaldson because i don't
know him i don't know his heart i don't
know what he actually meant but i know
um
you know he talked about tim anderson
referring to himself as jackie robinson
we've had a long history
of having to explain
how black people can refer to themselves
as opposed to somebody of another race
that comes into question in this
particular situation
oh
okay well yeah it's because of the times
we're in
the times you see
the times are spoken all the times the
new york times the cl seattle times
just like the general times all have
determined that in these times because
of the times
due to the times and given the times
which were in
a member of a protected class is allowed
to be a sensitive crybaby wildly
overreacting to even the most meager
slight and white people must simply bow
their heads submissively and affirm
whatever the protected person is saying
or feeling no matter how ridiculous and
unreasonable it may be such are the
times
now personally though i i must confess
that i don't um much care about the
times that we're in or what time it is
i believe in one standard for everybody
a standard which is not time dependent
marcus spears says that there's a long
history of black people having to
explain that just because they refer to
themselves a certain way doesn't mean
that somebody of another race can refer
to them the same way and this rule now
apparently applies to jackie robinson
comparisons
but
this like i i also wonder how far so
like if a black guy says oh i'm six foot
one am i allowed to go and say well
you're six foot one is that i'm am i
allowed to say that
am i allowed to make any
statements or observations
at all i think the answer is no it's
racist
that's in fact what we've learned is
that if you're
if you're in a protected class
a privileged class which is the same
thing
then no one is allowed to notice
anything about you
but also
in not noticing anything about you
they're erasing and otherizing you so
they're they're racist no matter what so
it works out
but um
here's the other thing this rule that
marcus spears is talking about this is
not something that's explained he said
well we've tried to explain
um like you know that's you explain
something that's an objective fact about
reality right
no this is a privilege
that certain members of protected
classes have attempted to claim for
themselves you're not explaining it
you're claiming it
but it's not a privilege that anyone
should have the standard for everyone of
every race of every shade or color of
skin should be this if you don't want
people to use a certain word don't use
it yourself if you don't want to be
called something don't call yourself
that thing or anyone else that thing if
you want people to follow a rule follow
it yourself
act as you want others to act this is
the rule the golden rule in fact which i
did not make up but which goes all the
way back to jesus and matthew's gospel
that's a rule a standard which rather
than being dependent on the times is
timeless
and here's another rule which i think
you can also
well you can also find this in the
gospels though not stated exactly as
such but it's this um man up
stop trying to use your crocodile tears
and fake outrage to control people tim
have some self-respect
also you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show davos's
world economic forum begins as klaus
schwab informs the world the future will
be built by him and his friends that's
today on the bench bureau should give it
a listen